in Iraq there's a lot of stuff going on
we have there they've chosen a new
president but it's not the one that the
ambassador Bremer wanted and so we now
have this new man I'll Yahoo or do you
know anything about it I don't haven't
met in their 45 years old and also that
they have are the the question about
whether the Governing Council is going
to continue The Associated Press is
saying that the Governing Council in
Iraq has decided to dissolve immediately
rather than go ahead the White House is
saying that that the Governing Council
has voted and excuse me that the
Governing Council is going to go on and
continue which is better terrific way to
start the day especially for those of us
who consider ourselves Friends of Iraq
and of the Kurds it would be better in
my opinion if it went on and I don't
know how the vote broke and I didn't
want a party out of 22 members of the US
appointed body agreed to disband well I
don't want to second-guess them there
are a number of them I know have felt
for some time that they're a governing
council only a name that decisions are
taken either in their absence or over
their heads or even elsewhere I mean
even not in Baghdad and again they're in
the meanwhile of course us to run
tremendous risks I mean the number of
them have been shot one of them one of
the women fatally so it's it's a hiding
it's nothing if you're asked to join and
I imagine people you know don't where
they don't sit by the phone waiting to
be wrong and hoping it's gonna be the
call to the Governing Council did you
Washington Post says this morning that
they now have 91 as the total number of
army investigation military
investigations going on in Iraq more
than what had been thought before glad
to hear it you're glad to hear it yeah
the more investigations do you think
that there are more instances there well
I think it's so let me put it like this
I mean it's to the it's to the credit of
the US Armed Forces that in fact we know
much of what we know
about for example Abu Ghraib which is a
place where I've where I've been I was
there lost around this time last year a
really horrific place with now everyone
knows and a double reputation for what
made it mez will call evildoing i said
you don't think it should be called
abuse which is a silly word and we say
child abuse as casually as we say
alcohol abuse prisoner abuses is torture
we ought to say so um to finish my
sentence sorry it's to the credit of the
US Armed Forces that we know most of all
we know because of its own
investigations you have these will begun
some time ago and fate seemed to be
fairly fairly honestly conducted you
have supported the president in Iraq yes
and area is that wavering at all has it
wavered at all in the last week's what
if you if you phrase this supporting the
president that's a separate question
from supporting regime change I suppose
but I don't want to take any opportunity
to seem as if I'm wavering I mean I
noticed some people are trying to
straddle the the gap there is a
difference between the president's
policy and regime change as a matter of
fact for example we the much despised
and put upon and abused alcaman Chalabi
among others has been calling for some
time for for many months for an earlier
transfer of sovereignty to Iraqis and
for earlier elections and I think
appalling mistake was made huge
opportunity missed in not doing that
earlier and giving the Iraqis the
impression of an occupation and that's
what we're having to make up for now mr.
Bremer who whose name keeps on coming up
I think did one very good thing which
was to replace the discredited Iraqi
Dena with the picture of Saddam on it
with something like a solid currency he
was a few cars reforms the first thing
he wanted to do and she got it done much
more quickly than one might have
expected but if you like that's the sort
of guy he is I don't take any of credit
for that away from him there was an
excellent thing to do politically and
economically give them some real money
but
there's a slight narrowness to that
vision if you see what I mean it's not a
matter of the fiscal and currency reform
alone
speaking of bastard Bremer the LA Times
says today that they they say that a
member of the is it Dawa the Dawa party
who was at the sunday meetings when they
were choosing this new president said
Bremer interfered and postponed the vote
they said that he came in and read them
the riot act how do you feel is the
United States having the in your opinion
right amount of pressure in terms of the
choosing of the next leadership in wreak
Dawa by the way in Arabic means the cool
it's the it's the cool and whereas it
makes from the minaret is the Dawa you
know what's the that's a that's an
Islamic party making this criticism I've
heard people say who don't want
Islamists or the council that the Bremer
is very autocratic maybe one hit one
who's been hearing that complaint for a
long time we're not put up her phone
lines invite you to join us your Steven
phone numbers at the bottom of your
screen Christopher Hitchens will be with
us for about 45 minutes we're talking
about any of the news of the day but we
might want to before we take our first
call talk a little bit about your slate
at peace that ran I think Sunday that on
mister Chalabi I think it was up by
Sunday yes it was it was on the web by
Sunday yeah what what were you doing in
terms of your support for mr. Chalabi
there well I thought someone should say
if he was because he seems to be the
scapegoat for a divided administration
in other words there many people within
the administration who are practically
at war with each other politically I've
never seen in I've been in Washington 22
years now so much open bitterness
between the State Department and the
Defense from the Defense Department CIA
these people are all pretty much strong
enough to avoid destroying the other
this is a sort of mutual assured
destruction if you like within the
administration but some of them seem to
have decided that they could all agree
to blame it all on someone else namely
dr. Challa beam and say well this is the
guy who got us into all this and I think
that's unfair but I also think it's on
untrue it's absurd on its face
if you're reading the paper and you read
that that's the only person who
persuaded the United States
administration that there were weapons
of mass destruction in Iraq and the rut
was harboring terrorists and so forth
was this sinister doctor with his sort
of forgery kit you have to just use a
moment of reflection I think common
sense it isn't possible that an
intelligence system service for which we
pay what is it 400 be linear can be just
enrolled and spun by an individual like
that and even if that's true which by
the way should mean a really big top to
bottom inquest and clean out of the CIA
which I've been arguing for for a long
time anyway wouldn't mind if the place
was closed and padlocked for a bit and
redone
how would it explain that has blix
believed that there were weapons in Iraq
the German intelligence believed the
weapons in Iran the French intelligence
said there were weapons in Rome that
Syria voted for the resolution that
suggested there were weapons zero that
can't that cannot possibly all have been
the work of the Sinister Delta chalabi
he's a very brilliant man I've known him
for quite a while and extremely
persuasive but he couldn't have done all
that it stands to reason why did it all
happen because of Iraq's track record
it's just it's simply common sensical up
till then every single time that the
question had been investigated Saddam
Hussein was found to have been lying
concealing blackmailing or murdering or
intimidating his scientists preventing
them from talking and endlessly seeking
new ways of getting the hold of WMD in
fact I think that he was still trying
that if you look in the Kaye report
there's one very interesting long
section of it based entirely on Iraqi
documents that shows that in last March
in Damascus
Saddam's people were meeting with Kim
Jong Il's people secretly to try and buy
the North Korean weapons system off the
shelf and the production lines to make
it the meeting broke up because the
North Koreans panicked because the
Coalition was moving into place around
the robert right up until march they're
trying they're still in the club that
includes North Korea Iran Libya and
others who have a sort of private market
in illegal weaponry
now that club has been quite badly
broken up since the intervention in Iran
this is why I'm still on the side of the
regime change forces Libya has
surrendered its arsenal by walking back
the origins of Libya's Arsenal we know a
lot more about where all that stuff came
from from a private racketeering group
in Pakistan one of our former allies and
from North Korea and we know that we all
support the UN inspectors of court the
Iranians cheating and now there's a vamp
us the riots have been found to be
cheating on their nuclear development
and we don't have quite where that's
going to go but the situation is a lot
more transparent than it was a year that
was before so ago and it's a lot more
advantageous from our point of view we
know more about it we shot quite a lot
of it done in every case they'd hugely
underestimated how much the Iranians had
for example gravely underestimated how
much the Libyan said had totally
underestimated the threat of illegal
dealing in Pakistan and were more or
less trusting the North Koreans now
that's over if the right side to Iran in
receiving intelligence reports in Iran
would be the side of having a nasty mind
a suspicious mind
any other policy would have been quite
irresponsible I think Christopher
Hitchens firstcall Union Oklahoma good
morning
mr. Hitchens number one thank you so
much for being one of the very few
objective journalists left regardless is
in the White House you've always shown
an objectivity that plays well out here
in Main Street America and I wanted to
get your I wanted to get your take on
the media's coverage of Abu Ghraib
I mean Main Street America I mean I see
people like Andrea Mitchell and Chris
Matthews talking about how this is on
the minds of American people but I don't
see it I think the only place that this
even plays anymore because you can't
turn on the TV without seeing a all-star
panel discussing this I think the only
place that it plays anymore is the
golden ghettos of Manhattan and
Hollywood it doesn't play in mainstream
America we understand that it was wrong
we understand we're dealing with it I've
got one thing to say to the Katie Kirk's
and these folks the world's get over it
Oh get over it we're not dumb we know
what happens it's time to move on mr.
Hitchens well I mean
about golden gets it but I suppose
number within the beltway elitist I do
try and get out there when I can
actually I find people are very
interested they're worried and it's true
some of them feel that that it's gone on
too long or it's been overplayed but but
I think people also feel a sense of
alarm if they don't they should of
course it's not as bad as Abu Ghraib
used to be I could tell you things where
everybody will curl your hair like what
well I mean not to not to talk about
anything obscene or graphic then but
demean simply a few years ago that was
decided by one of Saddam's sons that the
prisons were overcrowded which they were
so was decided they would basically do a
cow of random of the prisoners but lists
were drawn up is to execute go up two
dozen people a day in every Bay but I've
been to the execution pitch it's this
terrible hole in the concrete with a bar
a beam and several nurses on top can't
imagine how horrible it was I really
when I was there thinking I'm glad this
place is being cleaned out and repainted
and taken over but there's something
horrible about it maybe be better you
know just start again but I mean
unfortunately needed a prison in a hurry
sorry I'm giving you such a long answer
but anyway the the the guards in the
prison got the list of the people who
were due to be culled and drove around
their families went to their homes and
bowed and said how much will you pay to
keep your relatives off the list to be
cold next week that's the sort of thing
that was going on to say nothing of the
kinds of torture and mutilation that
actually you may have seen last week the
seven Iraqi business men who'd had their
right hands amputated our grab for um
dealing in dollars and had their
foreheads branded as well that they will
they've all been re constituted now they
got prosthetic arms they've had the chat
is removed by volunteers in Texas which
I think you'll agree is middle America
mainstream America well Europeans think
of as cowboy America the Texans took
care of that for them and I was very
pleased to see there was that got
recognized in the newspapers but look
what happened in our grave in the last
few months last year was paid for by our
tax dollars it's therefore our
responsibility we didn't pay forces I'm
saying to amputate these people that's
not our responsibility in the same way
we shouldn't mention that in the same
breath we have to face what we have done
or been responsible for and make sure it
doesn't happen again and and I think
very very severely punished the traitors
and cowards and and giggling
recreational sadists who thought it
might be a laugh to not just do this but
to make them cheap little videos of it
for their amusement and for our
discredit perhaps very difficult actual
you see to to say too much about this to
cover it you're not a little rock
arkansas morning
yes thanks Connie what a pleasure it is
to finally get through to c-span I'm a
junkie I don't have a question and a
couple of quick observations if I may
mr. Hitchens what makes you believe sir
that we should have supported this Ahmed
Chalabi
knowing that he's a convicted felon
wanted in Jordan for bank fraud and
embezzlement number one number two Bush
has shown his contempt for democracy by
snubbing his nose of the world to the
United Nations and he has also shown
contempt for my Christian faith you know
the golden rule is do unto others as you
would have others do unto you preemptive
strike is just the opposite of that
preemptive strike is based on fear it's
a do unto others before they do it to
you based on fear that is just the
opposite of the golden rule that is
anti-christian now that was a command of
Christ not a suggestion
thanks little rock I have tried to find
out what occurred with dr. shadow beyond
the Petra bank in Jordan the Bank Petra
and I can safely say that I don't know
because it's an extremely murky business
they thought was I don't know that it
isn't true
and I'd nor do I know that it is and
neither by the way do you or do any of
the other people who say they know that
he was guilty wanted in Jordan you could
seal convicted it was a it was a
military tribunal that did this
investigation and had it done that
verdict military tribunals don't
normally do bank fraud cases the the
counter suggestion made by dr. Chaffee
who says he can prove it and says he has
documents that will I don't trust him
necessarily to be right on this but it
deserves to be said that his case hasn't
yet been presented is that that was the
revenge through the Jordanian apparatus
which was quite close at that point to
saddam hussein for his antiserum
activities in jordan again I can't I
can't but I would say I know that's true
either but it's the side of it that this
least often mentioned if you're
interested in fraud and misappropriation
I hope you've been following the UN
oil-for-food scandal and the
unbelievable criminality and waste and
misallocation there appears to be
involved there I mentioned this not as a
matter of moral equivalence but because
you mentioned the United Nations as if
it was something that had this sort of
sacred or constitutional power in the
case of Iraq it had failed repeatedly to
enforce even its own resolutions and not
only that but was acting in direct
collusion possibly for corrupt motives
through its bureaucracy with the Iraqi
regime I think that state of affairs has
been allowed to go on far too long I'm
not a Christian or believer venya in any
other faiths I can't I don't want to
adjudicate between you and the Nazarene
and President Bush but I think probably
Bush could use being told off more often
that he isn't a Christian because he too
often claims that he is my view about
preemption is that if you don't favor it
then perhaps you've done and then people
should stop attacking the administration
for failing to foresee 9/11 because
there's only one way that I know of that
could have been prevented and that would
have been the bombing of the al Qaeda
camps at least the bombing number
perhaps the dropping in by parachute of
a force to take out the al Qaeda camps
in Afghanistan and that that would have
been getting a retaliation in first
there's no other way than what we saw
could have been stopped impossible not
even that would have worked Los Angeles
good morning yes good morning I find
some of your comments quite interesting
mr. Hitchens I really do because any of
us who have followed the Middle East for
any length of time and I've been
involved in the peace movement in Israel
Palestine for the past 40 years clearly
understand that there are two
occupations going right now in the
Middle East one in Iraq and one in
Palestine and the American public funds
both of those occupations so just one
quick comment about your WMD the reason
that most of the people in the area
wanted weapons of mass destruction is
because Israel has them Israel has more
than any of them so when you look at the
abuse in places like Abu Ghraib and some
of the other places and Shalaby they
have all been underwritten by the
neocons in Washington and I'm kind of
interested what you think about this Jon
the Israel who many of us who follow
through the internet recognized as an
Iraqi national who is Jewish and was
probably under the control of either
Mossad and and/or Shin Bet I think a lot
of the torture that happened in Abu
Ghraib was a direct teaching from the
torture that the Israelis have done to
the Palestinians yet the Vanity Fair the
LA Times you never cover that I'm
curious as to whether you are going to
cover that um on your first point there
were only two occupations in the Middle
East I would say that so much myself
would say that the occupation by Syria
of Lebanon would would count and some
would say that the occupation by Turkey
of Kurdistan would would count too but
you'd be wrong you're right in saying
that Israel did introduce weapons of
mass destruction to the Middle East and
I've written a couple of articles more
than a couple actually about Mordechai
Vanunu the Israeli whistleblower who
revealed the fact that actually that we
already knew but made it a certainty and
independence on detail and also showed
how Israel had cheated and broken all
the rules to acquire
that weaponry then you say so you find
so far you might think but when you say
that's why other people in the Middle
East want the weapons of mass
destruction because Israel has them I I
just think she'll flat-out mistaken if
Saddam Hussein had had a nuclear weapon
he would have used it on Iran or another
another Muslim country the use of the
chemical weapons that he did have was
always on Persians and Kurds Shia and
Sunni Muslims it's naive to think that
he would have tried to do anything about
Israel after all Israel could have from
so to speak defended itself the other
thing you might bear in mind since you
care about the Palestinians is that if
Saddam Hussein had used those weapons in
Israel or in the Holy Land wherever we
agree to call it he would have been
killing Palestinians as well as Israelis
there isn't a weapon you can that kind
you can use that discriminates between
them Jews and Arabs now the second oh
yes the neocon cabal well I don't know
anything about John B Israel I should
specify but I suppose I get up to a
hundred emails a day telling me that
there's a Jewish neoconservative cabal
in Washington I'm I'm getting bored with
hearing this as an explanation and I
have to say not in your case I'm also
getting slightly irritated by the tone
of voice that underlies some of that I'm
sure you can guess what I mean and
though it's not at all unlikely that
Mossad would be helping with the
interrogation process I don't think that
what we saw in those videos is borrowed
from Mossad one of them will I'll tell
you just one reason why do you know
something not everyone was points out
with those torture and humiliation
videos no claim has been made even that
was being done to extract
important information from dangerous
people everybody knows that there's a
real moral and theoretical problem about
having in your custody someone who is a
member of something like al Qaeda may
have information that's time-related
and i everybody knows that there are
permissible precious that can be brought
in impermissible ones that must
and the Israelis have been trying to
walk that line discipline very strongly
by the way by their in Supreme Court
which ruled against a physical torture
the that if the Mossad would I think
have the same contempt anyone would have
for these antics these sordid sadistic
antics of the kind of will we've been
seeing so this in case any of that helps
you to discriminate a bit my offer is
for Christopher Hitchens next call
Vancouver Washington yes I'm the
first-time caller
mr. Hitchens I can't believe that you
don't know and leaving your own heart
that this was not necessary that's more
the thing of it is it they knew that
they maybe had flyovers there they
didn't have any anti-aircraft guns to
shoot us down they had no air force they
had no Navy and and had that figured out
ahead of time we'd walk in there and I
just think that it was a misleading the
public to ever do that and with his
private army of privatization we have
people there they're privatized during
the tour tree getting a billions of
dollars from the people here from the
citizens for war profiteering it's not
necessary thank you thank you thank you
ver well god I must be earlier than good
it's very soon we would take a very long
time for me to tell you all the reasons
why I think that the confrontation with
Saddam Hussein was inevitable as well as
desirable in other words in the sense of
being necessary but you actually you
touch on one of them we had in fact
never stopped being at war with his
regime since the invasion of Kuwait
there was basically only long armed
truce
in the course of which between 1992 and
2003 sanctions were imposed quite quite
punitive ones which the CIA with as
usual brilliance thought would bring
down the Saddam Hussein regime within
the year which gravely distorted and
punished
to the Iraqi economy and society made us
co-responsible with Saddam Hussein
actually for running Iraq meant that we
had in fact inherited Iraq has a real
responsibility I don't see how that
responsibility could have been
discharged without saying well first off
we're going to stop cooperating Co
running the place with Saddam Hussein he
goes we start again without him but I
wish myself that had been done in 91 I
think we'd be living in a much better
world if it had been that's I think the
neoconservatives were right on that
point they would have got blame for it
then too but they would have been they
would have been dead right the
intervening 10 years saw this terrible
damage to Iraqis society and the
production of this this half staffed
half educated underclass that we're
seeing now which arrived didn't used to
have and second it gave ten years for
Saddam Hussein to Islam Assizes regime
to stop pretending to be a secularist
and come right out with it and say he
was for holy war put the words Allahu
Akbar god is great on the Iraqi flag
stop pumping money to fundamentalists
and Islamic fascist groups within and
and outside Iraq the people we're now
fighting now the confrontation with them
was unbearable too but if you just let
it run it would have gone through the
Saddam Hussein regime which was in a
terminal phase through the delightful
period of rule by his two sons and I
think might even have quarreled and
ruled successively rather than together
but that would have been a gorgeous
thing to see and then would have been
taken over by people like motor solder
and mr. czaka we and there with a really
major state a really important country
and a very important Society would have
been lost worse than Somalia or Rwanda
and we'd now be having an inquest into
how on earth we let that happen I think
it was done too late and you're right in
saying it was done with too much um
upbeat suggestion that would be it would
be easy but that it was necessary and
that it was inevitable I do not doubt
and neither should you the flag on your
lapel is the flame of Kurdistan is so
which I think one one would have to say
was one of the unarguable successes of
the regime change policy mean the
northern provinces of Iran
sometimes called Kurdistan we're about a
twentieth of the population live I think
about 300 American soldiers there and
they don't even have to wear helmets
there are four female High Court judges
20 newspapers a huge amount of
reconstruction and rebuilding going on
it's it's real liberated territory and
this is the most important and what the
largest minority and the middle east in
fact the largest people in the world who
don't have a a state of their own but
they of course have been free of Saddam
Hussein's control since 91 shows what
can be done with regime change if you do
it in time Lawrenceville Georgia good
morning good morning pleasure to talk to
mr. Hitchens I've been watching you
following your career for a number of
years and I'm always interested in what
you have to say I am I was very amused
by something you said the other day
about about how a European see mr. more
Michael more tans day I got a really
good circle out of that one but you
can't congratulations by the way on
becoming a citizen shortly I heard yes
I'm I'm it's the private the paperwork
is beginning as it will yeah good good
well III think kana should be somewhat
chastised for not asking the most
important question and since Brian lambs
not there I figured I would call it
asked it
are you still a socialist you may not
know this Tony this back story I've been
doing this show since 1982 right now I
remember the look of sheer horror well
no that's not true she never would
betray such thing with a mild shock that
crept over brands inscrutable features
when I told him with my socialist
convictions and every time I came back
he would keep on asking me are you still
and I think I probably went on saying it
saying yes fractionally longer than I
should have done really just not to give
him the satisfaction frankly I didn't
want any celebrations on the right your
hip shins in the light or that kind of
thing but the truth of the matter is
that it it and all other party
attachments have fallen away from me
died in me somehow over the last few
years I don't identify with any ideology
now or any any faction
anymore so to that extent I can't say
that I am now but I don't think I wasted
the time that I was I mean a socialist
that's to say I mean there were a lot of
things I did when I was on the left or
sad or believe that I would certainly
repeat and only wish I'd done more about
you're gonna share with us what you
shared about Michael Moore it's awful it
you know sometimes you do your best to
try and make a serious point you do an
analysis of as it might be regime change
and Curtis tone but what people really
like is when you go ad hominem and I
regret to say I gave into this impulse
the other day we're more or less said
that Americans excuse me the Europeans
think of Americans as fat lazy
provincial greedy Oh fish vulgar and
complacent and so on and it's how odd it
is that the Europe's favorite American
seems to be someone who has all those
characteristics next is terrible thing
to say really but someone had to say
Farmingdale Long Island yes mr. Hitchens
first of all Iraq and Iran during World
War Two they were impressed with the
Americans they wanted to break the
chains of colonialism and imperialism
Qasim in Iraq and Mossadegh in Iran they
looked up to America as a land who
kicked the British into French out of
their country and they poured their oil
profits into developing a secular
socialist states that produce more PhDs
than we have in this country per capita
and they reduced religious authority by
forcing religious schools all peoples of
all faith to go to effect together in
the same schools I mean both countries
developed doctors of both sexes what
happened was the United States overthrew
Mossadegh with the Shah and got the
Ayatollah we overthrew pass him in
during the Nixon Bush administration
then we got Fadem insane in power the
CIA put him in power when Qasim wanted
to take over Kuwait back I think it was
in 61 try to get rid of the the oak of
victims that the British imperialist and
French and and Turks and everybody else
are trying to create and we just we just
stir the fires of fanatical religious
faiths not only in in Afghanistan but in
in Yugoslavia it's all a game it's a
chess game for the oil companies and
these built us burgers or whatever they
call them that maybe you have become
part of I know Clinton is and I know the
rest of you are it's a disgrace to the
human race what we're doing to these
people we destroyed the core I would
like to answer this question I'd like to
answer you back sir fine well it's it's
a I was find it depressing when I'm
confronted with something that's half
true such as what you began by saying I
mean it is as far as I know I shall
write a book about it just being
reprinted as a matter of fact just
recycled it's called blood class and
Empire yeah about the inheritance by the
United States especially the British
colonial institutions and practices and
alliances and I described in there what
happened in Iran in particular within
the 1950s and generally speaking
anywhere gent until you started going on
about Bilderbergers and conspiracy
groups and the rest of it you you'll
quite loose it sir and I was with you
you're wrong about this the oil
companies in flaming religious hatred in
Yugoslavia I don't think that's true at
all
but you were doing splendidly and indeed
it's it's a it's a critique the many of
us have made of American policy in the
region there it has relied on proxy
powers local dictatorships or military
elites the hope of the removal of the
Saddam Hussein regime was that it marked
a break with that as indeed it does very
risky break but I think is very
necessary one and the fact of the matter
is that in Iran now the most the most
popular symbol is the Stars and Stripes
young people set it onto their jackets
they they think of United States as a
secular in plural country of the sort
they'd like to live in instead of the
depraved theocracy they do have to live
under let's give you a clue there are
some ironies in other words in the
American policy I like to say that we
we're the ones it was well it was
Theodore Roosevelt son that went over
there yeah overthrew the Mossadegh
regime we had a chance to have very good
friends over there and they would have
given us to Durban they nationalized the
oil industry why the heck did the
British landlocked
Iraq when they created to raid it's just
to seek them we we support these
kingdoms okay caller what we've done to
the world Thanks
Thank You Farmingdale appreciated your
coughing he's right about covered
Roosevelt's and I feel that is true he's
not quite right about Kuwait I mean the
British did draw Sir Percy Cox was his
name he did draw the border between them
Iraq and Kuwait doesn't completely land
lock Iraq Iraq does have a cursor there
and by the way Kuwait wasn't has existed
as an entity since before the British
got there there is such a patience
Kuwait it's not just a just not just to
shake them but it's amazing when you
look at it if you look at the general
world horizon the foreign policy today
you think the partition the border in
Pakistan and India and Kashmir Cyprus
Palestine Ireland the border of Iraq
Saudi Arabia Kuwait all these drawn in
in the Train century by British civil
servants trying to widen down the Empire
get the hell out of there there's even a
book about it called divide and quit
huge amount of American policy is based
on cleaning up after British Empire the
gentleman is essentially right about
that
Chicago's good morning hello there yes
I'm curious as to whether you know about
the book written by Katherine crook it
is called stolen youth the politics of
Israel's detention of Palestinian
children now I I was born there and I'm
part of women in black which is a
Israeli women's peace group I have been
there many many many times and for you
too so cavalierly say that the Israelis
do not practice torture it's just not
correct at all they
only do the torture but they are busy
torturing at the moment 2,000 young
children between the ages of 13 and 17
so I think that when you say things such
as Israel is not involved in the in the
torture of the Iraqis or in teaching
them it is not correct because that's
where the hood came from its where the
tie-downs came from any of us who have
been there for many many years 14 with
the Palestinians
we know that Thank you Thank You Chicago
let's let mr. Hitchens respond Salaam I
think you misunderstood my my last reply
by the way I did not say there was no
torture in the occupied territories or
tortured by spiders no magic and I said
I was pretty sure that that would have
been more sad advice to the American
operatives in in Iraq what I was trying
to say was this the the Israeli Supreme
Court has found cases of and heard
because of the suits brought amount of
things by bets elem the Israeli human
rights organization I'm sure you're
familiar with the dude occasional
Marrakech the torture and has said there
are some things you may not do the the
certain kinds of physical force that
can't be employed now this is a horrible
business was once you start trying to
codify too-tall you'll probably already
tainted with it but the everybody knows
that there is tourism what I described
is a moral of theoretical problem about
what to do about non-state combatants
who's not who's tactics involve the
infliction of civilian casualties but
whose aims are the infliction of
civilian counties as well that's known
as what they do it's what they want they
want to end up with a system where the
human life is meaningless this is a
problem and one can't just emotes about
it I think because in the end the jihad
forces are going to be defeated because
in fact all Jihad's always lose because
probably because of their inner
rationality probably because what they
demand is impossible partly cuz they
start squabbling among themselves we're
going to be doing this for a very long
time I believe we should be extremely
patient and extremely careful about it
and deny ourselves any form of extremism
in the
in the exercise of reprisal or
interrogation we can afford to be
patient that's my view but it doesn't
mean we shouldn't be ruthless crime so
excuse me what did you add something
yeah when the first core who's being
echoed by this one said about the two
occupations in the relationship between
them the Israeli occupation of the West
Bank and to some extent of Gaza is based
on the preposterous idea that there is a
biblical warrant for Jewish Israeli
domination of these areas that it's
given them by God in other words I've
always believed that the Supreme Court
should rule the no American aid could go
to this because it would be violation of
the establishment of religion Clause of
the First Amendment if for no other
reason however it's the United States is
not in Iraq on that basis and doesn't
say we're here because God wants us to
be and he's given us Iraq and all its
people and OS resources so to that
extent the comparison I think I think
Falls doesn't not
Cranston Rhode Island good morning mr.
hedges I have to disagree with you sir
the whole Europe my charity of the
Europe let's put it this way things that
Israel is posing a threat to war peace
what are you saying about the Europeans
about the American people's now they
think that we are this fan and all these
stuff I have to disagree without you sir
because I think the Europeans they look
as America's as one sided that we are
helping out Israel and in it's all right
to help out Israel Israel is a great
nation and what is doing to itself now
you will pay later what they should do
is they should move back to 1967 border
as the first step and give to the
Palestinians whether it belongs to
Palestinians the Jewish people I'm sure
they want peace and they're nice as my
people and I don't know why they killing
each other and then it will be a fresh
step towards peace because Iraq well I'd
have some claim to be European myself so
I didn't think I made at least
illustrate to the point that there's no
such thing as
a general European opinion and I polish
him to suggested there was in my cheap
shot at mr. more Island well you can
have my opinion for free there there are
two peoples living in Palestine and the
obvious solution for a long time since
before 67 seems to be as they each have
a state that's even implied in the
Balfour Declaration that's the founding
document if you will
morally a generator for the State of
Israel if there's to be a Jewish
homeland there it must be without
prejudice to the rights of the existing
inhabitants it's as simple as that if it
wasn't for religion it could be done too
but unfortunately the the extreme
Zionists though they they they're having
some second thoughts now even in the
Likud Party about the idea of Eretz
Israel for Greater Israel mandated by
the Old Testament but they still
maintain anyway that there's nothing you
can do it's beyond human control this
was given by God it doesn't take much to
get Muslim extremists to echo that and
say well no this land actually is all
Muslims should go back to the Caliph
Asian and then in the United States
there are large number of Christian
Zionists who hope that this tussle can
help to bring on Armageddon and is it
the second or the first I can never
remember coming of Jesus Christ this
these kinds of irrational cultist
movements some has called monotheistic
religion make what is an obvious
solution impossible but the majority of
Jewish American voters have whenever
polled registered support for a
two-state solution and the majority of
Israeli Jewish voters can still be found
for that proposition so they this
there's still some hope that the reason
can prevail over the over the faithful
Melbourne Florida
hey good morning she's been I got two
statements I got off the US House of
Representatives and one quick question
the first statement is that when you
recall the president and others made
repeated references to the unmanned
aerial vehicles that they told us were a
threat to the United States that Iraq
could fly over Americans right biochem
weapons I mean I don't wanna you know
okay okay but the president told us that
that our Intel services were telling us
that was going on well let me tell you
that what the United States Air Force
was telling the president quote the Air
Force does not agree that Iraq is
developing UAVs with the primary
intention of delivering biochem weapons
the United States Air Force stated that
the small size of the Iraq's UAV
strongly suggests a primary role of
reconnaissance and my other statement is
the speech made to the UN by Colin
Powell when summing up the story goes :
pal this is from the US House of
Representatives by the way okay : pal
made of speech had the CIA analyze it
and discuss it with him they even
drafted the speech which then went to
the White House but when it emerged it
looked totally different and the story
goes that the vice president and his
chief of staff a national security
adviser and national security staff were
involved in this caller when you say it
came from the House of Representatives
what do you mean I mean what are you
reading from it was a representative
Williams Delahunt which is an excellent
speaker I always see him up there were
I'm wondering from maybe an Intel
perspective if you go overseas and look
at the terrorist attacks it's always
like a bomb but every single a terrorist
attacks its gonna happen here it's gonna
be some spectacular whose huge event
like why is that what's going on there I
mean the difference in the size yeah
it's gonna meet them Thank You mr.
chance well taking it in order I mean
what he says is I'm not sure about the
reworking of the current pal George
Tenet presentation by the White House he
I don't know that I know that but I know
I know that that it's true that
secretary Powell and George chana were
closeted for a long time and George sat
behind so first a part in making the
speech to
certainly indicate that they were right
behind him the agency was right behind
him on all this he takes us back to the
very first question you asked me all the
second question actually about both
Shelby secretary plowers always disliked
intensely does Charlie and George Tenet
has been trying for a very long time to
sabotage and on him unde under mine him
than discourage him the CIA is hated
dr. Charlie for about a decade that the
guy's two worst enemies in the
administration backed by a four hundred
billion dollar intelligence operators
mega presentation of the UN which is
found to be full of holes and it's all
blend on Chaubey people really must
start to get real about this I didn't
really understand the second half of the
question and I do think I'm holier folks
I don't think you did either yeah I
don't know I mean I I think what he was
asking about was why is it as it were
things that go off statically rather
than a conveyed by some other force to
monumental explosion I know people who
spend all their time worrying about what
can be smuggled into the United States
by ship either through the sea ways or
the harbours and how difficult it is to
patrol the high seas how easy it might
be to get a weapon of mass terror on
board while there's I don't know but I
think we'd be speculating I would start
to babble well your citizenship papers
come through in time for the election
I'd probably not Homeland Security seems
to have taken over the is now I mean
there's a tremendous paperwork backlog
people are getting lost in it but I
don't think I'll be able to vote now are
you going to speculate on who you would
vote for if you could sure know if it
was I'm a single-issue voter and so I
guess must have become apparent and I'm
not a Republican I'm not a conservative
I'm not very great admirer of the
president in in many ways but I think
that I my condition is that the
administration that wakes up every
morning wondering how to make life hard
for the forces of jihad
and how to make an attractive as far as
possible an unapologetic defense of
civilization against this kind of
barbarism and though the Bush
administration has been rightfully
disappointment on this and incompetence
is nonetheless feel they have in some
sense that spirit and don't get that I
didn't get that feeling from anyone who
even sought the Democratic nomination I
have to say so if it were today you
would vote I have to vote for the
reelection the president yeah yes I
think I would Chris Richards thanks for
joining us this morning thanks really
we're gonna be talking more about energy
and oil the next we have